I'm going to talk about geodetic calculation and visualization.
I'm Bjorn Zimmerman
, scientific content
manager
of wolfram alpha
, another company in the wolfram family.  Published With the
latest products, it's now easier to create great maps.
You can see this feature in the Geodetic Data and Calculations at the Document Center
.
I'd like to talk about calculating geodetic information as much as possible, but
you can also see it later in the Document Center.
What really does it take to make a very flexible geodetic cheese?
Graphics are a very powerful part of the wolfram language and can be used in a variety of ways
,
one of which is the visualization of geodetic information used here. The
wolfram language is geodetic.  Computations are also included The
wolfram language includes geodesy calculations from version 7 so
you don't have to build it from scratch and can build it on top of existing ones.
You can use wolfram's knowledge base, which
means you can take advantage of many realities.
Many realities and polygons in Alpha have location information associated with them.
It's easy to use these information to visualize geodesy.
Wolfram's cash register base also has urban tiles and elevation data.
Geodetic system 3 There are
many ways to model the Earth, depending on what pride you can use and which ones
you actually use, but they all have in
common.  Each method means that 1 is
represented by latitude and longitude. In
wolfram language, the coordinates are represented by the salt position.
You may have noticed that the standard packlet, for example country data, has changed and the
tio position is now a polygon.  Now returns
This means that you can now handle things in a tentative
way.If given is a polygonal salt position, then the nightlet is also 10 positive.  Returns what
was wrapped in a monitor As I said earlier, 10 positions have latitude and latitude information,
which used to be the opposite
and used longitude and latitude as it can be easily plotted in graphics.
This feature is now built into the latest products, as we now need to be able to use the salt position in the graphics. The
salt position has been expanded as it becomes more widely used. The
salt position is an array.  It now takes arguments and
can automatically convert
inputs. It supports more input formats and
also supports quantities introduced for external users in his previous version.
I also use wolfram alpha. You
can also use dms strings and geotagged images in the salt position.
If you use geotabbed images, you
can easily retrieve information about where the image was taken. This information can be found in
the meta information of the image.  Included
There are various types of salt
positions that have been expanded on a case-by-case basis.
10 Projection data has long
been exposed to external users in the Wolfram language, but with the addition of two new projections.
Chiyo Displacement is very useful for describing routes
Previously, for example, an upper distance between 11 and 12 could be used
to describe traveling a specific distance in a specific direction.  Ginsei Zashio distance Beat
I was able to enter something like Knitted Beaorin in a Wien position.
This is now easier to describe in Child Displacement in the latest version.
There are various types of documents.  The
documentation has been significantly updated for the latest version, but the
salt distance has also been
extended to support reality and distance functions.There are
two polygons and their  I want to find the distance between the centers of one or two polygons where the two polygons are closest to each other
.
These are now easy to specify.
Many of these geographic functions are similar to wolfram alpha in body shape.  Supports
mate living in a country that uses the metric method  Users under the Le Act
will use meters or otherwise imperial units such as miles.
Newly introduced demand distances can handle expanded realities,
for example within 100 km from Germany at Salt Nearest.  You can ask for all the countries in
Talk For example, the city of New York is for finding out if the United States is in China, etc. In
this case, yes. For a
demand entity, for example, you can look up a building in New Orleans
.  I will talk about information visualization. Fishing information
uses the coordinates of the two layers before and after Toei
. We have expanded the graphics supported by users
so that they can be used geographically.
Geographical location here.  In
this way the champane is returned and
you can get information such as what is around it and where you are now.
You can click on it to see the latitude and longitude. Click on it
using a map source.
You can copy and get the position that can be used on different maps
This is explained in detail in the documentation
Most options are automated I want to optimize the results I get after evaluating once
If you want to know more about this or want to use this feature more, check out the options to
see in detail which auto-configuration was used
, for example you can also see the meta information for annotations,
such a small area
You can also see that the Mercator projection, which is a common format for
Masu Futaba Collection 6 Level
What kind of data is currently available? As I
mentioned earlier, there are urban corner tiles around the world from zoom level 1 to
local zoom level 18. The
selected range is the product.  As you can see, the system tries to show in suitable ordinance inches the
same for elevation data
Elevation data is currently up to level 8 We are
currently working on adding an elevation data map with a higher tap resolution.We
plan to have a child in the near future, but it is not included in the current version yet.
However, this has already been added to the wolfram alpha site
. You can easily use them even before the release of a new version of Matty or
10 Projection Settings
10 There are many types of projections in the next version.  More
will be included.
This is also currently under construction.
Salt model As I said
earlier, there are many models that represent the Earth, such as
children. Good data includes wgs 84, which is used for gps coordinates.
You can also use custom elliptical parameters and realities with a good map, for
example you can use exactly the same for Mars and the Moon You
can also use the Geogrid line head or you can plot anything
There is a blog post about Apollo's lunar landing that you can see in detail. The
salt scale bar is very useful. This represents the current scale. The scale that
suits your situation is automatically selected.
You can easily annotate the map with the award marker. There
are many predefined icons and it is easy to mark the map. The
salt path is a path on the surface of the earth.
If you use a normal line between two points, you will dig in the earth.The
salt path can be used to represent the route on the surface of the earth.
Used to easily represent a specific distance travel to the
Meridian Parallel arctic circle
There is also a name next path such as Tropic of cancer
Tide groups can group primitives with salt graphics
Futaba wanting ding  You have to be careful that you post to normal graphics support,
but it's
very powerful.
Textures can be used for non-uniform salt styling.
You can add it on the actual map and
also that map.  You can also use a tooltip on top
There are various predefined Futaba stylings
Increasingly
, it's now easier to create contour maps of normal city maps without outline map labels.
You can also use image effects and adapt without the charcoal drawing effect
.
You can do anything with
detailed documentation on these as well.
Salt list plots and salt region value plots are supportive.
For example, you have a good camera that can capture gps coordinates and take a
picture and finally download the picture  Suppose you wondered if you took this picture with Ryoko. You
can easily find out where you took the picture while walking, whether it's a champane or a flower
. You can also display
gps coordinates on a map.
Connected device  It's easy to establish a connection with your device using the media. You
can also map to wolfram. How far
is this champane to the other offices of the wolfram family
? I
won't cover it here.  As you can see, I'm using an interpreter here. That's
all. Thank you for your attention.